hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and in this video
I will explain all the different races
Clans and factions into seven deadly
sins story and its sequel the Four
Knights of the Apocalypse in fact a new
race was just officially introduced in
the sequel and it could be the strongest
one yet so we have a lot to talk about
you guys know the drill if you enjoy our
seven deadly sins videos and you want to
see more in the future leave a quick
like and comment right now it only takes
you a second but it helps me out with
that YouTube algorithm and a reminder
that well over 50 of you guys who watch
our videos are not subscribed to the
channel do me a big favor and subscribe
right now and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
is completely free and it's also the
only way to make sure that YouTube will
actually notify you when we publish
another seven deadly sins video now I
actually made a video about all the
races and Clans and seven deadly sins
like five years ago but a lot has
changed since then including the release
of the sequel so an extensive update
video is long overdue let's start it off
with the humans who might seem like the
least interesting race because hey
everyone watching this video is probably
a human but humans actually become more
important towards the end of the
original manga and their importance
continues to grow in the sequel that's
because we eventually learned that all
race has emerged out of an ancient
primordial deity known as chaos chaos
created the Supreme deity and the Demon
King first and from them the goddesses
and the demons were born chaos then
created the sacred tree out of which the
fairies were born the fourth race to be
created were the Giants although their
primitive desire to constantly fight
each other disappointed chaos and so
chaos decided to create a fifth race the
human race the humans were incomplete
and contradictory beings they exhibited
both kindness and cruelty bravery and
coward is love and Loathing Beauty and
beastliness and so on because of this
chaotic nature the humans were closest
to chaos and so they were the perfect
race as far as chaos was concerned this
infuriated the demon king and the
Supreme deity and they became jealous of
the humans they were afraid that chaos
would turn against them and take away
their Realms and followers so they
turned against their own Creator they
worked together to seal chaos away and
once they succeeded in that task they
became the two most powerful beings in
the world they became the gods of
Britannia although humans are usually
weaker and have shorter life spans than
members of the other races they also
have by far the largest population this
is partly because the deadly holy war
from 3000 years ago resulted in Mass
casualties among members of the other
races which dwindled their numbers and
forced the survivors to live in isolated
secluded pockets of Britannia on on the
other hand humans spread all over the
land of Britannia and established
multiple prominent kingdoms unlike
members of the other races most humans
are born without magic but they are able
to learn or awaken magical powers later
on in life prominent examples of strong
humans include the holy nights Mages and
Druids all of whom are able to use
powerful magic and although they are
rare some humans like Bon and escanor
are able to hold their own against even
the strongest members of the other races
but to be fair that is because they both
had access to extraordinary magic that
normal humans never will bond drank from
the Fountain of Youth which made him
Immortal and allowed him to push his
body beyond all human limits and escador
possessed Sunshine a divine grace that
once belonged to mael the strongest of
the four archangels humans can also
become hosts to much more powerful
beings such as when Margaret became a
host to Ludo shell or when Arthur became
a host to chaos its cell in such
instances the person becomes far
stronger than a normal human but their
personality seems to change completely
and they are no longer the same person
that they once were we also need to talk
about some distinct subgroups within the
human race starting with The Druids
Druids are a group of humans who live
deep in the forest far from ordinary
human settlements they also worship the
goddess Clan directly and because of
their allegiance to the goddesses they
tend to despise the demon Clan The
Druids look like normal humans although
many of them tend to have silver hair or
white hair unlike most ordinary humans
The Druids are much more in touch with
nature with animals and with the spirit
world and they are able to perform
magical spells and techniques that
normal humans cannot these spells
include the ability to heal as well as
the power to destroy dark and corrupt
Souls such as the souls of demons these
are all techniques that they share with
the goddesses and It is believed that
these techniques were taught to The
Druids by the goddesses as a reward for
their devotion another important
subgroup of humans are the Wizards who
once inhabited the city of Billy allowin
Billy alawin was known as the capital of
the Wizards and its inhabitants have
been referred to in multiple different
ways including sages wise men and
wizards Billy Allen is the hometown of
Merlin the boer's sin of gluttony and in
fact she is the last known Survivor from
the capital of the Wizards the entire
city was destroyed by the demon king and
the Supreme deity during the previous
holy war from 3000 years ago at first we
didn't know whether the Wizards were a
separate race altogether because Merlin
had stated in the past that her true
name cannot be pronounced by humans
which kind of implies that she herself
may not be human nevertheless in the
final Arc of the original Seven Deadly
Sins it is confirmed that the
inhabitants of Bali alawin were in fact
human but they were a special group of
humans who were obsessed with research
searching magic in fact they took
children who had a particular affinity
for magic and experimented on them
relentlessly in order to find the
ultimate magic power Merlin herself was
one of the children who was experimented
on by the Wizards now let's talk about
the Giants who look almost exactly like
humans but they are just much bigger and
stronger Giants are known for their
incredible physical power and Warrior
culture they tend to Value strength
courage and Glory above all things and
the leader of the giant Clan is chosen
based on which Warrior is the strongest
Giants have a close connection to Nature
and to the Earth in the holy war that
took place 3000 years ago the giant Clan
fought alongside the goddesses fairies
and humans against the demon Clan
however an important figure in the
history of the Giants droll became a
member of The Ten Commandments and was
sealed away alongside the Demons Inside
the coffin of Eternal Darkness droll is
a legend among the Giants he invented
the sacred Dance of the Giants but after
being defeated in battle by zeldris
droll decided to join the Ten
Commandments and he became the
Commandment of patience despite being a
giant droll differs from the average
Giant in appearance because his skin is
blue and he has forearms instead of two
because Giants are famous for being
Fierce Warriors they were often hired as
mercenaries and sent to fight in various
Wars between human kingdoms throughout
history now initially we were led to
believe that the Giants were close to
extinction and that there were only a
few of them left in Britannia but both
the seven deadly sins cursed by light
movie and the sequel manga have
demonstrated that there are indeed other
Giants out there that we didn't even see
in the original manga so I'm no longer
sure just how endangered they really are
giants live much longer than humans in
fact they age about 50 times slower than
a regular human and they also have a
special ability called creation which
allows them to control and manipulate
the Earth much like the Earth vendors
from Avatar The Last Airbender Giants
can use the Earth to form great and
powerful weapons that they can then use
against their enemies
then we have the fairy Clan fairies are
also very human-like except they are
smaller and have wings that look like
the wings of insects they also have
pointy ears and a childlike appearance
unlike humans and Giants fairies are
born from the sacred tree or plants that
grow around the sacred tree as such they
do not have parents although those
fairies who are born from the same plant
are considered to be siblings the
fairies have extremely long life spans
ranging from 1 000 to 1500 years
although certain fairies like
locksinia's sister get her they can live
for over 4 000 years fairies have
multiple unique abilities including
flying because they have wings
shape-shifting manipulating plants and
reading the hearts of people in order to
determine whether their intentions are
pure much like the Giants the fairies
fought against the demon Clan during the
ancient holy war and interestingly
enough just like withdrawal and the
Giants one of the strongest and most
important members of the fairy Clan
eventually became a member of The Ten
Commandments I am referring to gloccine
the very first fairy King who became the
Repose of the Ten Commandments and was
also sealed inside the coffin of Eternal
Darkness fairies lived peacefully inside
the fairy King's forest for thousands of
years and at one point the grisly sin of
sloth King served as the fairy King and
ruler of the forest but he eventually
left the forest in search of his best
friend hellbrum and the task of
protecting the forest fell to his
younger sister Elaine 20 years before
the beginning of the story Bonn entered
the fairy King's forest in search of the
Fountain of Youth and he met and fell in
love with Elaine however the forest was
then attacked and destroyed by a Red
Demon Bond managed to survive because
Elaine made him drink from the Fountain
of Youth and turned him into an immortal
but Elaine herself was killed and the
forest was destroyed before she died a
Elaine gave Bon a seed that he could use
to restore the forest and some years
later he created a new fairy King's
forest in the human world fairy wings
are thought to have magical healing
properties and for this reason the wings
of a fairy can fetch a very high price
as a result fairies have sometimes been
killed by humans for their wings each
fairy apparently smells like a specific
flower or herb so for example King
smells like goldosmanthus and Elaine
smells like lavender next up let's talk
about the goddesses members of the
Goddess Clan also look similar to humans
but they do have one distinctive feature
that instantly sets them apart that
feature is their large white angelic
wings with lower ranked goddesses
tending to have only one pair of wings
and higher ranked goddesses having more
the ruler of the Goddess Clan the
Supreme deity who resides in the
celestial realm appears to have at least
five different pair pairs of wings she
is also enormous in size bigger even
than the tallest giant although the name
goddess Clan can be deceiving there are
both male and female goddess clan
members the goddesses have been fighting
against the demons for thousands of
years and even though the goddess Clan
was on The Winning Side of the ancient
holy war they also suffered major losses
in order to seal away the demon clan
members of the Goddess Clan had to
sacrifice their ability to maintain
their physical forms when the seven
deadly sins Story begins they are able
to possess inanimate objects such as a
sword and they can use the body of
another living being as a vessel but
they do not have a physical form of
their own goddesses are said to have the
longest lifespan out of all the races
and every member of their Clan seems to
be able to live for thousands of years
the goddess Clan has its own special
Elite Force known as the four archangels
the four archangels are all powerful
male angels and the highest ranking man
members of their race second only to the
Supreme deity and her direct descendants
their strength is set to rival The Ten
Commandments which is the elite fighting
force of the demon clan members of the
Goddess Clan are known for a number of
unique abilities including the power to
heal the ability to fly and the ability
to purge and Destroy Dark Souls such as
the souls of demons their powers
associated with light and Holiness and
their abilities can be extremely
effective in fighting against the demon
clan in particular there is also a
subgroup of the goddesses known as the
celestials they are descendants of the
Goddess Clan and they lived in the sky
Temple where they were almost completely
isolated from the rest of the world
although they were allied with the
goddesses because they lived in such a
remote location the celestials were
removed from the worst effects of the
ancient holy war as a result they
survived the war and did not lose their
physical forms but over time their wings
became smaller and their magic became
weaker so once we meet the celestial in
the present time they are considerably
weaker than full-fledged goddesses
although they still have long life spans
and similar Powers including Arc and
various healing abilities the celestials
play a major role in the prisoners of
the sky movie but they are also directly
referenced in the manga so they are
considered Canon at some point the
celestials came to believe that the
demons won the ancient war and that the
surface of the world was conquered by
them this is part of the reason why the
celestials chose to remain at the sky
Temple and live in isolation from the
outside world and speaking of the Demons
let's discuss this incredibly powerful
Clan although many of them look
monstrous and demonic in some way the
members of the demon Clan are actually
quite diverse and their appearance
varies greatly there are many different
types of demons from lesser demons were
identified primarily by their colors
such as the gray demons Red Demons Blue
Demons white demons and so on to higher
rank demons who often have a humanoid
appearance many of these humanoid demons
still have some distinct features which
distinguishes them from humans such as
demon marks on their bodies but some
demons like meliodas can assume a
completely human-like form because of
this meliodas can easily pass for human
and initially no one around him even
knew that he was a demon despite the
fact that he was living among humans and
interacting with them every day aside
from the external features demons also
have unique internal features that
differentiate them from members of other
races for instance demons have more than
one heart and higher ranked demons can
have up to 7 hearts demons tend to live
about a thousand years although the
highest ranked demons have demonstrated
the ability to live for multiple
Millennia as we learn in the early arcs
of the seven deadly sins story humans
are able to consume the blood of demons
and become stronger because of it but
those who are not compatible with the
process will reject the demon blood and
their bodies will explode a human who
has been exposed to demon blood and has
managed to master it within their body
is able to use certain demonic attacks
like hellblaze during the ancient holy
war the demon Clan battled against all
the other clans combined including the
humans fairies Giants and goddesses the
demons were ultimately defeated and
almost completely sealed away inside the
coffin of Eternal Darkness with only a
few exceptions a Red Demon who somehow
managed to avoid being sealed away ended
up destroying the fairy King's forest
and fraudrin the selflessness of the Ten
Commandments had been sealed away
separately but managed to escape when
his seal was broken by some humans he
then went on to possess as the body of
the great Holy Night Dreyfus frame the
seven deadly sins for the murder of
zaratras and he ultimately released the
other nine members of The Ten
Commandments from the coffin of Eternal
darkness and of course there's meliodas
who is also a member of the demon Clan
but was not sealed away along with the
other demons the ruler of the demon Clan
is the demon king and the demons come
from a place known as the demon realm
The Demon King is the most powerful
demon and the father of both meliodas
and zeldrus at one point The Demon King
took half of his power and split it into
10 pieces then gave each piece to one
Elite demon warrior in the form of a
commandment this is how the Ten
Commandments were created and they serve
as the demon Clan Special Forces who are
specifically trained and equipped to
destroy the enemies of the demon Clan
melioris himself was once a leader of
the Ten Commandments before turning his
back on them and betraying the demon
clan in order to be with Elizabeth
members of the demon Clan are extremely
powerful in general and they are known
to look down on the other races demons
tend to see humans as especially weak
and pitiful and they are known to feed
on The Souls of humans in order to
replenish their magical powers that said
there are demons who reject this type of
thinking and who actively avoid war
meliodas is of course a good example of
this but there are others such as an
entire Village full of demons who
decided to Desert from the battle during
the holy war and live peacefully in the
Dal Flair mountain range powerful demons
like members of The Ten Commandments can
control lesser demons and many demons
possess a number of unique abilities
including demonic Darkness the power of
flight the power to generate deadly dark
Flames called Purgatory fire that can
injure even an immortal without them
being able to regenerate the ability to
steal Souls the ability to transform
into the unbelievably strong indura
Beast of destruction after sacrificing
six of their hearts to do it the ability
to regenerate and so on and now that
we've covered both goddesses and demons
we need to talk about a new race that
was created as the result of the
unprecedented Union between a demon and
a goddess between meliodas and Elizabeth
their son Tristan is given a special
classification in the sequel called the
Four Knights of the Apocalypse he is
referred to as a Nephilim the impure
child of a demon and a goddess Tristan
is the only known character in both the
original series and the sequel who is a
natural-born Nephilim we have seen other
instances of someone using both demonic
and goddess magic like mile slash Esther
Rosa but Tristan is the only true
Nephilim from birth this means that he
has unique powers and abilities that no
other character possesses he has the
power of both light and darkness now
some might question whether just being a
hybrid offspring of a demon and a
goddess qualifies as being a member of a
separate race but I do believe that
Nephilim deserves special attention
because it was introduced as its own
unique concept even though there are
other hybrids in the series like for
example Lancelot Tristan wasn't just
referred to as a goddess demon hybrid
Tristan was referred to as something
specific and something that already
exists in our own world and to me this
indicates that nakaba wants us to pay
special attention to Nephilim in our
world the Nephilim have historically
been described in many different ways
depending on the source and the
mythological tradition in some sources
they are described as Giants in others
they are described as fallen angels in
others still they are Angel human
hybrids and finally in some sources they
are angel demon hybrids like with
Tristan actually Tristan's case is extra
interesting because his father is a
demon and his mother is a goddess in a
human body so Tristan technically has
goddess demon and human characteristics
and that human aspect could prove to be
important because of the unique
connection between humans and Chaos oh
and speaking of chaos as I mentioned
earlier in the world of the seven deadly
sins chaos is a primordial being that
created the world and all of its races
Clans and species out of nothing Merlin
describes chaos as an impure entity of
Darkness that even the demons fear and a
pure entity of light that even the
goddesses worship chaos was likely
inspired by Greek mythology in which
chaos is a void state that comes before
the creation of the universe the first
generations of gods in Greek mythology
actually emerged out of chaos which is
similar to how the demon king and the
Supreme deity were created by chaos in
the seven deadly sins however chaos in
the series is more than just something
that exists before the universe is
created chaos still exists and still
interacts with the world but after it is
sealed Away by the Supreme deity and the
Demon King it takes the form of the
mother of chaos the same creature we've
known all along as Hawk's Mama the
mother of chaos is also the mother of
all the monsters and monsters are
another group of of beings that exist
within the world of the seven deadly
sins on top of the five major races
there are various subgroups of monsters
including vampires beastmen and
creatures who live in purgatory the
vampires were allied with the demon Clan
during the holy war but they are not
actually part of the demon Clan and they
were treated as subordinates by the
demons vampires look like humans but
they also have sharp fangs and they are
able to turn humans into Vampires by
biting them the humans that they turn
will then be compelled to serve them the
vampires tend to feed on human blood and
as a race they are stronger than humans
and have a much longer lifespan the most
notable member of the vampires is gelda
who is of course the lover of zeldris
beastmen are creatures who have a
humanoid body but the head of an animal
and they also have claws fur and other
animalistic features the only beastmen
that we really got to know in any
significant way in the story is Zhivago
a fox man or were Fox who took by on in
as a child then raised him zivago was
shown to be able to transform into a
human even though that is not his true
form so it is possible that like fairies
all beastmen have the ability to change
their appearance in order to look like
humans beastmen have strong animalistic
abilities and instincts but they were
driven to the break of Extinction by
humans historically humans have feared
the beastmen and seen them as monsters
kind of like stories about evil
werewolves in our own world and so the
beastmen have been haunted by humans and
they've been driven into hiding and
forced to steal from others in order to
survive aside from Zhivago who is a were
Fox the other beastmen that have been
mentioned in the story include jivago's
son also wear fox and a wolf man or
werewolf that meliodas and Liz were sent
to hunt down in the past
creatures from purgatory are monsters
who were created by the mother of chaos
and who inhabit the incredibly extreme
and inhospitable environment of
purgatory these creatures often have
features similar to the animals in our
own world but they can be a mixture of
different animals and they are often
massive in size they can also live for
millions of years that said they can
also look pretty normal say like an
ordinary pig that just happens to be
able to talk Hawk is actually a creature
from purgatory who was stolen from his
homeland by The Demon King and brought
to Britannia to spy on meliodas Hawk
himself was not actually aware of this
until later on in the series finally
there are some beings in the seven
deadly sins world that don't fit under
any real labels such as for example the
Lady of the Lake who was also created
directly from chaos but doesn't seem to
belong to any specific race or group
there are also creatures who were
created artificially through the use of
extremely powerful magic a great example
of this is the goats sin of lust
golfther who was actually a lifeless
doll but he was brought to life by the
demon golfer over 3 000 years ago and as
the Four Knights of the Apocalypse
sequel manga continues I'm sure that
even more interesting races and
creatures will be introduced to the
story eventually I look forward to
seeing what nakaba has in store for us
next
if you want to see more seven deadly
sins and 4 Knights of the apocalypse
videos here on the channel leave a like
and comment right now oh and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel so
you'll be notified when the next video
drops if you're looking for a video to
watch next then don't ignore this video
which ranks the Four Knights of the
Apocalypse from weakest to strongest
check it out right now you can click the
link on screen or in the description